if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others
you need to understand your values
that's why the minimalist created a
free downloadable and printable values
worksheet
that will help you identify all of your
different values
and the obstacles that are in your way
head on over to theminimalists.com
v to download your free values worksheet
today
enjoy minimalists
how can we as parents help messy kids be
less
messy aside from being an example
ourselves
i like that because the implicit
question of this is like don't tell me
that i need to also be less messy or
whatever
right uh and and
also what they're saying is i get it yes
they lead with your own behavior but my
kid is
messy now what yeah so
we build that visual cortex we build
that visual processing system
the one that has to do with space and we
do that from the time they're very young
we show them black and white objects so
they get a sense of
of dimension and space and and we
um as they get older uh we have them
track moving objects balloons that fall
through the sky so that they're building
that visual cortex
as they get older we give everything a
place so
with my two-year-old we had stations
this is where your balls go
this is where you um you eat your food
this is where
we read stories this is where you sleep
and we in a sense rotate them from one
station to the next
um but by doing that they start to
recognize that things
have a location things have a space
as they get older one of the pitfalls we
fall into is we get our kids
everything and when you do that it
becomes
almost impossible to recognize how to
give everything a space
i like to recommend you know having five
or ten toys out
and everything else boxed up and put on
the shelf and if they want if they're
done
then they say okay we can clean up one
of these and we can get out something
else so that they recognize that any
task has a beginning a middle and an end
that's a different of the steps
everything has an order
beginning middle night you play with the
toy you you take out the toy you play
with toy you put away the toy
um but you give everything a space so
they know where it is
they know how to clean up and then they
move on to the next thing but if you
have everything all over the place they
don't think about that
they just play play play play play and
then they're buried in
you know army men and and and dolls
overstimulated
really chaos in a way too right and so
the stat is that the average kid has
approaching 300 toys on average and
plays with what 12
weekly and so or daily or whatever the
stat is
but regardless it's it's such a small
portion of the overall
and yet it's easy for
a kid especially have all of that chaos
strewn throughout
their room and of course you're going to
feel overwhelmed amid
chaos and so if i look at this question
differently
it's not about math so much as it is
about order
and it's about taking the time to
consciously think about
where am i going to put things if i put
my keys in a different pocket every time
i misplace them i can't oh my gosh
they're not here right when i was a kid
i used to lose my keys all the time when
i started driving
i'd go play basketball with my friends
i'd leave it on the court or i'd go to
the beach and they'd
i always ended up finding my keys
somehow but i lost them so much
that i had a hanger that i used to put
under the bumper of my car
so i could make a little hook and break
into my car and i kept the spare key
under the mat
and it worked wow it was great it was
great until my friends at school
realized that i used to do that and then
every day at lunch they'd move my car
and after school i was
wandering around looking for my car but
after i got married my wife put a basket
by the door
i haven't lost my keys in 25 years i
come home my keys go in that basket it
has a place
yeah now i know how to uh get into uh
your car
you can't break in as easy as we used to
be right well you know
what when i think of christian's
question here my brain goes to
uh reward and consequence
and so what you've covered is like how
do you help your
children set up boundaries how do you
kind of help them understand not to be
messy but there's a certain point where
you know maybe there needs to be a
consequence or maybe you entice them
with a reward like
i guess overall like how do you feel
about you know
consequence versus reward when do you
when you present consequences when you
present the carrot when do you present
the stick i think cleaning up at at this
age i think did they say five or a young
child i don't think there wasn't
so age here yeah the you know when
they're young kids it's really about
teaching
it's about it's about learning it's not
about consequences because
they don't recognize it as a value or an
important thing
it's when we're done with something we
put it away and then we do something
else
and that's a lesson we teach wait wait
you want something else let's clean up
and then we can all go to the park
that's the reward the reward is inherent
in the next thing that they get
to do now if they're a 13 year old
and grandma is coming over and you say i
need your room cleaned by three o'clock
then you know you're gonna have to stay
there until you get that thing cleaned
up you're not going out with your
friends you're not doing whatever
until you get that done oh interesting
so what i'm hearing you say is again
depending on the development stage you
offer the reward which can be something
as simple as just moving to the next
thing going to the park eating
dinner or uh if a 13 year old maybe
there is some kind of consequence of
well now you have to stay in your room
until it's clean yeah it's not a
punishment
right the reality is this is the
priority it has to happen before you get
to do those other until you before you
go on the internet before you
use your phone this is what has to
happen yeah yeah each morning
ella she and it's clockwork now she
brushes her teeth she makes her bed
and she knows those two blow dries her
hair and
she gets dressed and the funny thing is
she loves wearing dresses she'll like
the first thing she does she goes gets
up in the morning and she puts on a
dress
that god love her brushes her teeth
makes her bed
horribly by the way
do you go in there and remake it every
morning i i yell at her and i say
you're never going to get in this is
horrible you didn't do the dishes right
last night you didn't make your bed
right this one no look this corner does
not bounce off the bed oh my goodness
no i i i always as horrible as it looks
every time it's always
a hey thank you so much for making your
bed great job um
now at some point there will be yeah
they'll be
me showing her how to maybe improve that
if
she so desires because by the way making
of the bed is simply my
expectation it's not going to help her
live better necessarily
i know jordan peterson wants you to
clean your room and i want her to clean
her room too
but um and i understand the psychology
behind that but but but it's important
to realize that
yes um making her bed brushing her teeth
getting dressed in the morning those
things have to happen before she can do
the things that she wants to do which is
always watching the dragons videos